tony hawk's pro skater 1 and 2 remasters
are coming this year iron man vr gets a
new release date
and capcom is planning multiple major
titles i'm chasity and this is your save
state for tuesday may 12th
it's tony hawk's birthday but we're all
getting a gift because tony hawk's pro
skater 1 and 2 remasters are releasing
this year
the remastered tony hawk's pro skater 1
and 2 collection is coming to ps4
xbox one and pc via the epic game store
on september 4th
it has updated graphics and new tricks
but not every song from the original
soundtracks fyi
however it does have all the levels
skaters tricks and modes from the
original games
this includes create a park and create a
skater with new customization items
you can share your parks online and the
game supports both local split screen
and online multiplayer as for create a
skater all the options can be unlocked
just by playing the game at launch but
if there's a demand
developer vicarious visions is
considering offering micro transactions
for more customization options
if you pre-order the game you'll get a
demo set in the game's classic warehouse
level but there's no release date on
that demo level yet
it may not have all the songs but it
will have the best song superman by
goldfinger
i'm ready to put the ska back in
skateboarding what are your favorite
songs from tony hawk's pro skater
and from one legendary tony to another
get ready to become tony stark this
summer because iron man vr is coming in
july
iron man vr was initially set to launch
this month for playstation vr but it was
delayed due to the coronavirus pandemic
now it's got a new release date july 3rd
iron man vr uses psvr to make you feel
like iron man with your own ai display
as you fly through various levels
game director ryan payton says the
studio wants to make a deeply personal
and appropriately funny narrative
in which tony has to confront ghosts
from his past so what other superheroes
would you want to play as in vr
sony has revealed another logo ahead of
the release of the ps5
the new logo is for playstation studios
this branding will appear on games that
sony produces or develops in-house
and will be applied to sony produced
games that don't appear on playstation
consoles
the opening animation uses examples of
games like the last of us
uncharted horizon zero dawn and little
big planet of those games horizon has
been announced for release on pc so we
expect the logo to be used for that sony
wants the sloga to be a mark of quality
the branding will also accompany games
that sony produces with third-party
developers
what's your favorite playstation studios
franchise
the xbox series x frame rate is up to
individual developers
the series x can deliver up to 120 fps
gameplay but
not every game will hit that benchmark
for example ubisoft told eurogamer
portugal that assassin's creed valhalla
would support at least 30 fps on series
x
xbox marketing director aaron greenberg
said on twitter quote
ultimately it is up to individual
developers to determine how they
leverage the power and speed of the xbox
series x
earlier he said that 60 fps is the
series x's standard output
but those specs are still up to the devs
capcom has plans for multiple major
titles capcom put out its latest
financial earnings report which gives us
some hints toward what it's planning
capcom wants a new record of 28 million
units sold this financial year
and it has a three-step plan to achieve
that promote digital strategy via
expansion of sales regions and flexible
pricing
aim to release multiple major titles and
pursue ongoing sales for major titles
from past years
the multiple major titles bit is
particularly interesting especially with
rumors about a resident evil 4 remake
and resident evil 8.
i could always go for more resident evil
or maybe a new street fighter
what major titles do you want from
capcom
and finally ghost of tsushima will
headline ps4's next state of play
sony's next state of play is all about
ghost of tsushima which launches on ps4
on july 17th the 18 minute long state of
play airs thursday may 14th at 1 pm
pacific and 4 pm eastern
and will feature quote an extended look
at new gameplay footage including
exploration combat and more
watch it with us and stay tuned for more
ghosts of tsushima coverage on gamespot
and that's your save save for tuesday
i'm chasity and you can find me on
twitter at chastity underscore v or over
on gamespot universe
and for all the latest news stick with
[Music]
gamespot